good
evening I'm Jennifer vanvleck assistant
professor of history and the organizer
of the Yale International history
Workshop I would first like to thank the
Yale program for the study of
anti-Semitism and the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs for their generous
co-sponsorship of this talk I'm honored
to introduce my esteemed colleague
Timothy Snider as the inaugural speaker
for this year's International history
Workshop Dr Snider is the house and
professor of history at Yale University
and a permanent fellow at The Institute
for human Sciences in Vienna he received
his Doctorate at the University of
Oxford in
1997 he has written several
award-winning books including the
Reconstruction of nation
Poland Ukraine Lithuania Belarus 1569 to
1999 sketches from a secret War a Polish
artist's mission to liberate Soviet
Ukraine the red Prince The Secret Lives
of a Habsburg
Archduke and bloodlands Europe between
Hitler and Stalin bloodlands published
in 2010 won 12 Awards it has been
translated into 30 languages and was the
best Siller in six countries and I
should note that Professor Snider reads
10 European languages and speaks
five this year Professor Snyder received
an inaugural Andrew Carnegie Fellowship
as well as the hav foundation prize he
is a member of the committee on
conscience of the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum and he sits on
the advisory councils of several other
scholarly and nonprofit
organizations his most recent book and
the subject of this talk is Black Earth
the Holocaust as history and warning
which was published earlier this month a
current best seller and a New York Times
editor's pick Black Earth has also been
longlisted for the Samuel Johnson prize
the United Kingdom's most prestigious
non-fiction award please join me in
welcoming Timothy
Snyder
so when we when we think and talk and
read and write about the Holocaust today
it's very often as a matter of
remembering of commemoration of looking
for Rounds numbers to commemorate of
seeking survivors finding stories I I I
worry that this is a trail that is
Fading Into Wilderness I'm concerned
that the politics of commemoration lead
us too closely back to the politics of
identity I worry that when we treat the
Holocaust as a matter of memory rather
than as a matter of History we give
ourselves answers that are too easy of
course it's right to think that we as
individual should be concerned about our
own attitudes and the attitudes of
others of course that's part of the
lesson of the history of the Holocaust
but I I wonder or I wondered if it was
enough and now I'm I'm convinced that
it's not the case that I'd like to make
in the next 45 50 minutes or so is that
there is a history to the Holocaust
which can be understood that the history
that we might understand is rather
different than the history that we
generally remember and that if we get it
right the lessons that we draw for the
present and the future would be
different lessons than the ones we draw
now and that's important because whether
we like it or not we are already drawing
lessons from the Holocaust we do it all
the time but what if we understand the
Holocaust incompletely or even
incorrectly then we've drawn the wrong
lessons and we may be accelerating
disaster rather than preventing it so
having said that let me try to make a
case for what I think are the causes uh
of the Holocaust this is not going to be
a talk about memory this is not going to
be talk about culture this is going to
be a talk about interpretation this is
going to be an essay an attempt at
interpretation now I have I have three
hosts um I I've been invited by the
international history Workshop I've been
invited by um the Y program for the
study of anti-Semitism I've I've been
I've been in invited by the the Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs what I
would like to do in a way is to justify
these three invitations I I would like
to begin um by speaking about anti
semitism I would like to to to move
forward to make a case for international
history as the way to understand the
Holocaust and then conclude with a word
about what this might all mean for
Public Policy okay so to begin with
anti-Semitism it is a common place that
in order to understand the Holocaust one
must begin with Hitler but returning to
the primary sources rereading mine comp
rereading the second book rereading the
speeches the addresses I noticed a
coherence um a total quality to the
ideas which I hadn't noticed before and
which I think perhaps eludes Us in
general and I'd like to begin with that
I'd like to begin with a short summary
of what Hitler's anti-Semitism actually
was this is important because when one
considers Hitler's anti-Semitism it's
not just a matter of someone being more
anti-semitic than other people right
it's not just a transitive issue this
person is more anti-semitic this is more
anti-semitic this is more anti-semitic
it's not like that there are qualitative
differences in the kinds of
anti-Semitism that people believe in
that people work from and in Hitler's
case what we have is what I would think
of as a planetary anti-Semitism a chain
of reasoning um at the end of which
there's only one possible conclusion and
that is the eradication of the Jews but
what's the chain of reasoning the chain
of reasoning is interesting Hitler
starts from the premise that we as human
beings are races that races are like
species and what species do is compete
for land and food so they can propagate
he takes that as being the only true
thing about the world it's a law of
nature he says in mine comp like a law
of physics it's a certain that he says
as the law of gravity why might we think
otherwise why might we be under the
impression that friendship or love or
marriage or law or the state or a
political party or any other commitment
to human reciprocity exists has weight
matters or should matter why might we
think such things the answer Hitler says
is the Jews the Jews are responsible and
this is the radical character of
Hitler's claim the Jews are responsible
for every idea of human reciprocity
which distracts us from racial
solidarity from Hitler's point of view
all we should be doing is recognizing
Who belongs to our race and who does not
and fighting on behalf of our race
against everyone else taking land from
everyone else starving them to death
propagating on what had been their
territory that is all we should be doing
any intellectual distraction from that
says Hitler is Jewish any so it
Christianity and communism say Hitler
are fundamentally the same idea right St
Paul says Hitler is the same person as
Leon trosky right because any idea
whether it's workingclass solidarity or
Christian Mercy which allows people to
engage each other as human beings is of
Jewish origin right whether it's a
contract a legal contract right or
whether it's membership in the Socialist
Party ideas which seem uh contradictory
on the surface are for Hitler all of a
piece any idea which allows you to see
one another as members of humanity as
opposed to members of a race must be
Jewish now this has the conclusion and
Hitler spells it out quite explicitly at
the end of chapter 2 of mine comp and
other places that the only way to
restore human nature the only way to
restore the planet is to eradicate the
Jews the Jews are Hitler says a
spiritual pestilence G pestilence and he
means that literally they they infect
the soul and the only way to restore the
soul the only way to make people what
they ought to be then is to completely
get rid of the jeice they have to be
removed somehow from the planet now one
other idea for which uh Hitler assigns
the Jews responsibility which we very
often Overlook is science so we have the
habit I think the bad habit of
understanding the Holocaust or alitz as
some kind of height of scientific or
technological achievement it would be
better I think to begin from the
passages of mine comp where Hitler
explicitly says that the idea that
science can save us from resource war is
a Jewish Swindle that it's a Jewish lie
he's very explicit that any hope that
one has for science to save us from the
fundamental competition over land and
food which is Our Fate that that idea
too is Jewish just like Christian Mercy
just like Communist Revolution that is
also a Jewish idea in fact in of perhaps
understandably oft forgotten and
neglected passages of mine comp Hitler
explicitly says that the hybridization
of grains fertilizer pesticides
irrigation that these things will not
save us in other words the entire
package of technology that was being
developed mainly in Germany in the 1920s
and 1930s which after the war was going
to become the Green Revolution and
create the world of bounty in which we
all grew up most most of us grew
up all of us know that created that
world of bounty he' specifically denied
those things right um specifically
denied that technology could save us now
this is very important because if
technology could save us if science
could save us then there would be no
reason for resource word to be human
Destiny so Hitler specifically denies
that possibility what he offers instead
and now I'm moving towards a difficult
problem of translating these ideas into
practice what offers instead is a kind
of substitute for science what he offers
instead is the idea of laan Realm living
space laan's realm is the alternative to
science what Hitler does is he he he
argues that in fact if you're
experiencing anxiety about food that's
right if you're experiencing a sense of
catastrophe that's correct we have to
welcome ecological panic because that is
in fact the authentic Human Experience
of the world Panic is absolutely
normal any idea that you ought not to be
panicking about shortages has been put
in your head by Jews right so Panic is
normal and the resolution to panic is
what he calls laan's realm the thing
which will work when science doesn't
work is laan's realm now what does he
mean by laban's realm well in general
you know what he means it means habitat
it means what we might say now as
ecological niche laban's realm is a
space where a certain group of people
another race lives and in the simplest
form this idea just means that Germans
should go to someone else's habitat
starve them out take their land and
propagate that's the simplest version
but in a more specific version lean
realm intersects with his General ideas
about Jews because one of his Notions
and it's a popular idea then and it
remains surprisingly popular now one of
his ideas was that Jews were Communists
and Communists were Jews this was called
in in Eastern Europe Central Europe This
was called the judeo Bolshevik idea that
or the judeo Communist idea the Jews are
communists and communist Jews now what
that means is that there's a specific
political construction the Soviet Union
which is in Eastern Europe which is
going to be vulnerable why it's
vulnerable because it's a Jewish State
and if Germany seeks its living space in
the East against the Soviet Union
there's a kind of double oportunity the
Soviet Union will crack upon contact
with Germany because it's just a Jewish
State and so a war will have been won
against Jewish world domination and
destroying the Soviet Union but
meanwhile Germany will be able to seize
the fertile territory of Ukraine which
is the specific geographical location of
lean realm Ukraine was and remains
incidentally one of the most fertile
territories in in the world and the idea
was that Ukraine would allow Germany to
become self-sufficient it would allow
Germans to become prosperous and it
would it would move Germany into the
ranks of the world economic and
political Powers so the conquest of
Ukraine would change would change
Germans now here we take a step even
closer to politics right so maybe you're
beginning to feel feel the appeal of
responding to anxiety right maybe you
can understand a little bit how a
country such as Germany which did not in
fact feed itself and could not in fact
have fed itself from its own territory
without giving up its industry a country
which had been blockaded during the
first world war and indeed after the
first world war by the anant powers um a
country which had to rely on unrel
inherently unreliable International
markets for food why a sense of anxiety
might in fact resonate that's one step
towards politics here's the next step
lean has another meaning the other
meaning of lean aside from habitat is
something more like living room so what
we would say in American English living
room a comfortable place a place where
you might take your meals um a place
where you could put your feet up where
the slippers are or maybe the fireplace
is the lean in this sense incidentally
is still used in Austrian German
although not so much in German German
which is just one example of many of
that kind of linguistic history um so
has another meaning I don't just mention
this as a kind of semantic curiosity I
mention it because it's inherent in the
use of the word itself when Hitler talks
about laban's realm he is simultaneously
saying two things he is saying we must
struggle to destroy inferior races and
take their land in order to survive
right so he is he's arousing what we
might call survivalist emotions at the
same time what he is saying is and
literally at the same time in the same
sentence or in the next sentence he is
saying we must take other people's land
in order to have a high standard of
living in order to have a standard of
living which is not lower than that of
the United States of America which is a
connection that he makes extremely
explicitly and one must admit
intelligently in the second book where
he says that um Europeans look thanks to
radio and other Technologies look for
their ideas of standard of living not to
the real possibilities of their own
lives but to America right and what he
says and here what he says is very
similar to a whole lot of French theory
that people of my generation had to read
in college what he says is standard of
living is inherently subjective and it's
inherently relative it's not a matter of
satisfying people physically it's not a
matter of a certain number of calories
it's a matter of believing that you're
not behind anyone else so this is the
second definition of Le and Hitler
explicitly means this he says it
explicitly that this is what he has in
mind so he's combin in two things other
people must die in very large numbers
but far away from us so that we at home
can not just survive but have prosperity
and of course in Hitler's writings
there's also there's a very clearly
gendered element to this right Men Must
Go and Kill far away in order to satisfy
the inherently insatiable desire of
their wives for a certain standard of
living right and so there are two ideas
of ins iability at play here um we are
insatiable because as a because as a
race we we need ever more territory ever
more food in order to propagate right so
our Instinct our basic animal instinct
is insatiable and then there's another
insatiability which is a human
insatiability a political insatiability
or consumer insatiability or very often
one feels in Hitler's writings of female
insatiability we're insatiable because
no standard of living is actually high
enough right so long as we can look
across the Atlantic Ocean and see
someone else who might be living better
we're not satisfied so we're also
insatiable in that way so laban's realm
has to accumulate there has to be more
and more and more this can never end
this is what history looks like whether
it's a biological history or whether
it's a political history and I hope by
now you're beginning to feel the
politics come a little bit closer right
because the notion that standard of
living is relative is one that we
experience every day the idea that
people somewhere far away can suffer so
that we can have a high standard of
living whether we like it or not is not
so distant right from the way that we
actually exist so in these ways I'm
trying to help us get through what I
take to be a very difficult problem
which is how you connect Hitler's
anti-semitic ideas to political practice
right very often what happens in
discussions of the Holocaust is a is a
shortcut is taken one says well it was
all about anti-Semitism and one refers
to Hitler fine but that actually isn't
the answer that's the question the
question is how could ideas that are so
radical which were not in fact all that
popular in Germany or anywhere else how
could IDE that are so radical actually
come to inform policy right the the
answer to to the to the question of how
the Holocaust happened is not
anti-Semitism that's only part of the
question we have to work our way from
that radical view into German politics
into human sensibilities and then beyond
Germany so this brings me to the
question of of Germany in in in the
familiar way in which the Holocaust is
is is is recounted we spend most of our
time working through Hitler's rise to
power in 1933 then the so-called G
shalun making the N making the German
State more appropriate for Nazi models
and then we go into the second world war
what I want to suggest is that there's a
different way that we ought to be
conceiving of this and this has to do
with what Hitler says about the state
and here again I'm not going to try to
break what I take to be a common
misunderstanding about the Holocaust
when we think about the Holocaust we
have a tendency to say the Holocaust was
one repressive policy among others
carried out by a strong state which
cataloged its citizens bureaucratized
them administered them in a repressive
way concentrated them and killed them
this is a very it's a very powerful
narrative which comes from Ral hilberg
it comes from Hanah arand it comes from
Zigman Balman in different ways what I
want to try to suggest is that this is
basically wrong at the level of theory
what Hitler says about the state is
actually very interesting Hitler says
that um the race cannot sacrifice its
fundamental goals on the altar of the
state Hitler says in the natural play
of the racial struggle state borders
will dissolve in other words he does not
see the state even the German State as
something permanent or even is something
very important the state is something
which happens to be there but like
everything else it's there to be
manipulated in the service of the race
and by the way the same is true for the
German Nation I think we make a mistake
when we think okay Hitler was a
nationalist like other nationalists but
more so that's not how Hitler wrote
about the German Nation what Hitler said
was German nationalism exists and it is
a tool which which which we can use to
propel Germans into war right he didn't
care about the German folk as such he
believed that German national identity
was a political instrument that one
could use to throw the Germans into a
war in which they would become
themselves in which they would return to
their racial Essence okay but I'm
getting ahead of myself what I want to
talk about now is is the state because
if we can take a step back from the the
the the the the the the moment by-
moment narration of Germany in the 1930s
which has been done extremely well if we
can take a step back from that and take
Hitler's ideas seriously we notice
something which is very important there
is a basic contradiction between a
racial Anarchist like Hitler and the
seizure of power right if you happen to
be I don't mean you personally but if
you happen to be a racial Anarchist
taking control of a state is actually a
kind of problematic complicated almost
contradictory Endeavor because your
whole worldview as you've expressed it
in a very long book is that states don't
really matter ideas aren't really solid
the only thing which matters is racial
conflict so how do you solve then this
dilemma of of taking control of a state
or of trying to take control of a state
and and here's where things get
interesting because Hitler solves this
problem and in in my view this may be
the most important element of his
politics in the
1930s think about the SS think about the
SAA take seriously their self-definition
as racial institutions don't look at
their uniforms and think of them as par
militaries or as parate organizations
they're not think of them seriously as
racial institutions consider the role
that they take in in Hitler's rise to
power what they do is they discredit
existing state institutions by their
Street Fighting by their brawling by
breaking the law they discredit the
state they break down the viian the
notional viian uh Monopoly on violence
and they do it on purpose and that helps
the Nazis to come to power okay but this
is precisely The Dilemma if you come to
power with a racial ideology with the
help of racially self-defining groups
what do you do once you have power
because if those groups are consistent
if they behave consistently with their
own ideas the revolution should continue
continue continue continue the
revolution should devour itself in fact
it should destroy the German State
because it's against States in fact and
this this I think is is the inner
meaning of a very well-known event in
German history the night of the Long
Knives the night of the Long Knives as
you might remember is the moment when
the SS defeats the SAA it's the moment
when the leadership of the S is exposed
as supposedly corrupt homosexual and so
on many of them were killed many of them
were tried and the SS comes to the four
the inner meaning of this is as follows
the S led by annol were the people who
really thought that the revolution is
going to go on they were the people who
took these racial ideas seriously in an
almost naive way they were talking about
a second revolution after
1933 the SS proposed something different
what the SS proposed was we will
maintain some kind of law in Germany
itself and later on we will export the
racial potential abroad and this is the
secret to Germany in the 1930s it's this
resolution of this tension the SS
remains a racial anti-political
organization they are biting their time
they are penetrating the police they are
preparing the way to destroy other
people's States if you think about it
this way the concentration camp then
takes on a different significance
because what is a concentration camp the
concentration camps were run by the SS
that was the main thing they did in
Germany 1930s what is a concentration
camp all lawyers should know this
especially American lawyers a
concentration camp is a Zone without law
by definition a Zone without law if you
think about it that way the
concentration camp in Germany is not so
much a zone of exception or only a zone
of exception it is a it is an example of
what you're going to do once you get
Beyond Germany right because in effect
when the war starts what Germany is
going to do is to declare whole
countries thousands of square miles to
be Lawless zones and that's going to
create some of the conditions which are
going to make the Holocaust possible at
this point you're probably thinking the
notes are for a different lecture but no
they're actually they're actually for
the they're actually for this lecture um
so this is and this is where we have to
move into so that was that was
anti-Semitism now we have to move into
International history because one can
make the case that abstractly right
Hitler's ideas were anti-state one can
make the case inside Germany that what
was happening in 1930s was not so much
just the Takeover of a state but the
accumulation of potential to destroy
other states which I think is the right
way to think about it the buildup of the
verock was the accumulation of potential
to destroy other states and the the the
privileging and the support of the SS
was how you how what you was the
preparation for what you do when those
states are defeated militarily you then
destroy them as Nations you destroy them
as political units okay but that's all
abstract how does it work concretely
concretely Hitler's basic idea of how to
engage in international Affairs as we've
already seen is to destroy the Soviet
Union that is that is the big move okay
so all of the things which we in the
west really like to remember a lot like
the Battle of Britain or the landing at
Normandy or the French Resistance or
whatever it might be whatever was
fetishized you know in your particular
High School these things do not matter
from Hitler's point of view view they
are all distractions they are
distractions they're distractions from
the main goal what Hitler is trying to
do between 1938 and 1941 is get to a
position of fighting the Soviet Union in
fact he's trying to do it from 1933 and
this is the this is the missing part of
the story often because it has to do
with um polish German diplomacy and
polish history especially polish
International history disappeared behind
the behind the Iron Curtain at a certain
point but something very interesting is
going on so if you are so imagine for a
minute that you are in the German
general sta
I'm looking around for actual members of
the German no okay so imagine for a
minute that you're in the German general
staff you're looking at the world from
Berlin you know that the main political
goal of your leader is the destruction
of the Soviet Union there's a country in
between you and the Soviet Union that
country is Poland it has a pretty decent
sized Army what do you do Hitler issues
pretty clear instructions about this
beginning in 1934 the basic idea is that
Poland is going to be either an ally or
a benign neutral in a war against the
Soviet Union and the Germans
consistently from 1933 until the end of
1938 tried to recruit Poland for a war
against the Soviet Union and where
polish and German relations break is
precisely at the end of 1938 early 1939
when the polls when forced to give an
answer will you or will you not Ally
with us in the war against the Soviet
Union finally say no now from the Polish
point of view what had been going on is
that they had been trying to to keep the
Germans uncertain for as long as
possible because polish policy was that
we were keeping an equal distance
between Germany and the Soviet Union on
the logic reasonable but in the end
tragically false on the logic that
Germany can't start a war without us
because we're between and the Soviets
also can't start a war without us
because we're in between so that is the
Polish logic but there's also another
difference the Germans negotiating with
the poles and by the Germans I mean high
level people such as ging and
occasionally Hitler himself are making
the case to the polls that a war against
the Soviet Union is also the way to
resolve the Jewish question now the
poles are afraid of the Soviet Union and
they are also talking the Polish
leadership is also talking about a
Jewish question or a Jewish Problem in
fact it is Poland's explicit policy
after 1935 to find a way to rid itself
of 90% of its Jewish population given
that there were more than 3 million Jews
in Poland that's a very large number
that we're conjuring with but what the
polls did not understand is how you
combined a war against the Soviet Union
with getting rid of the Jews that was
the thing they could not understand
because from their point of view the way
to get rid of the Jews was and this is
where things get interesting and I spend
some time in the book telling this story
because it's largely unknown the way to
get rid of the Jews was to support
right-wing Jewish terrorists who are
going to make a lot of trouble in
Palestine so there could be a Jewish
State now that's that's interesting okay
that's interesting that that as part of
the prehistory of Israel that's
interesting but for the argument it's
important and here's why from the Nazi
point of view
anti-Semitism is part of this racial
Anarchy right the Nazi anti-semitic view
is that the Jews are the ones who are in
the way of a racial struggle which is
non-political the Polish point of view
is different the Polish point of view is
very much attached to the state they
don't understand that the nais are about
racial Anarchy they don't get that but
what they do understand is that the way
to handle whatever problem they're
defining even what they see as the
struggle against Jews is by way of
states right so you either negotiate
with the British or behind their back
you find a way to create a state in
Palestine and then you can get the Jews
sent off there so this actually is one
of the factors that leads the second
world war because Germany proposes to
Poland The Joint attack and in the end
Poland says no okay now why have I spent
all this time on this well partly
because I want I want to emphasize the
point that there are different kinds of
anti-Semitism right that it's not just a
matter of turning up a dial or turning
down a dial or answering like who is
more anti-semitic the Poes or the
Germans or something like that there
there there issues of quality here which
matter especially when the quality has
to do with the state and we'll see more
about that why that's why that's true
soon but where we've gotten to in
history is the moment where Germany
starts to destroy states where this
theory of State destruction actually
becomes practice where the SS are
allowed out of Germany because remember
inside Germany what the SS can do to the
German population is actually rather
limited the concentration camps are
terrible places but there were a few
thousand inmates it's only when the SS
gets Beyond Germany Beyond ger law
institutions practices that the SS
begins to do truly radical things so let
me now take a slight step back Austria
falls apart in March of 1938 the anlo
this means that suddenly lots of
Austrian Jews are no longer citizens
they're forced to scrub the streets um
tens of thousands of them are are are
basically expatriated very quickly from
Austria why is that so interesting it's
interesting because in about six weeks
Austrian Jews suffer about as much as
German Jews had done in the previous six
years and that is despite the fact that
in Austria there were no nberg laws
there was no political legal
discrimination of Jews but basically
from one day to the next with the end of
the Austrian State Jews lost their
protection from the state and then you
can do things with them that you could
not do in Germany right that's
interesting there was a limit to that
ironically because Austria was brought
into Germany itself and the moment that
Austria was joined to Germany then
things had to actually calm down rather
than accelerate Czechoslovakia is
destroyed over the of 1938 and 1939 by
this time Jews know what's coming they
know that the Civil codee's going to go
away they sell their property they run
so simult so so the the state
destruction of Czechoslovakia leads to a
similar consequence but Poland this is
where I'm going with this Poland is
special because Poland is where Hitler
finally gets his War it's not the war he
wanted it's not a war he had planned
it's not a war that he expected but when
he made war against Poland it was the
first war that he prosecuted while
actively destroying the state when he
talks to his high officer ERS um in in
in in in July August 1939 right before
the war August 1939 early September 1939
what he tells them is that this war is
not about is not like other Wars it's
not about territory it's not about
Victory it's not about seizing a certain
amount of land it's about destroying
Poland as a state and as a nation as a
state and as a nation other words not
just about um destroying the Polish Army
but about coming into the country
declaring that the civil code no longer
functions the Polish state does not
exist this is where it gets interesting
the Polish state has never existed right
so the claim that they make when they
enter Poland is basically the same kind
of claim that European imperialists made
um Beyond Europe right that the
territory we're entering is uninhabited
at least in the sense of uninhabited by
political beings so Poland is treated
colonially in the sense that the Polish
state is not acknowledged as an
institution actively not acknowledged
and the people who were thought to
represent presentent it whether they're
Military Officers whether they're
civilian politicians whether they're
Roman Catholic priests are physically
eliminated killed in the tens of
thousands and that's not an accident
that's part of the idea of destroying
the Polish state now the destruction of
the Polish state then um this new
radical step
moves moves the final solution forward
it allows for things that wouldn't have
been possible otherwise in this
situation for example something like a
ghetto is possible so when you think of
the ghetto you think about it in terms
of terrible images and human suffering
and that's all true but from a lawyerly
point of view the ghetto is a violation
of property rights okay it's a violation
of javious Corpus what happens to the
Jews is the moment where the Polish
civil code goes away they no longer have
the right to remain where they are that
may seem like an almost trivializing way
to look at the ghetto but it's actually
very important the Germans deliberately
take away rights from everyone which
means that anything is possible when
Jews are put taken to the ghetto that
means they lose the right to live where
they lived in that part of the city or
in the surrounding Countryside and it
means that other people can take their
property which is extremely important
right because that means that millions
of people are immediately implicated in
a certain way in what's happening if
only in the very simple sense which it
turns out to be pretty fundamental of
not wanting their Jewish neighbors to
come back the German German destruction
of the Polish state opens uh opens the
path towards this settlement that opens
the path towards ghettos it makes things
possible that hadn't been possible
before but I'm going to note something
which is interesting the German invasion
of Poland is in September 1939 the
Germans don't invade the Soviet Union
until almost 2 years later the June of
1941 in those intervening two years Jews
suffer tens of thousands of Jews die
mostly these are Jews from the
countryside who have to come to the
cities who have to come to the ghettos
who don't have personal connections
that's the key factor if you come from
the countryside you tend to lose
everything and also you tend not to know
anybody in this new ghetto where you
arrive and those are the people in the
huge majority who die and the figures
are in the tens of thousands in Warsaw
which is a hor something like 60,000 in
Warsaw which is a horrible figure but
the point that I'm trying to make is
that this is not yet a holocaust the
Germans are not actually taking Jews out
in large numbers and killing them um
Jews are dying but the way that they're
dying is not yet this thing that we
think of as a holocaust and this is why
I want to stop and pause and just
emphasize this point you can go all the
way through German history all the way
up to 1939 from 1933 to 1939 in Germany
the total number of Jews killed is about
200 right so the first six years of of
Hitler's power the total number of Jews
killed is about 200 you can even go into
the war in Poland and the creation of
the ghetto and the total number of Jews
who die is in the high tens of thousands
right um before the war in the Soviet
Union which is awful but it is not yet
the Holocaust and what I'm trying to
resist is the kind of story which says
things kind of just got worse and worse
and worse and somehow we slipped into
Mass killing what I'm trying to claim is
that they did not slip into Mass killing
that there was a particular moment which
was a turning point for reasons um which
I'm going to try to explain and that
turning point is the invasion of the
Soviet Union okay now there's some
reasons that we all know why the
invasion of the Soviet Union would be
important why why it might be critical
the Germans fought the Soviets in what
they called a war of extermination fikun
the idea from the very beginning I mean
from mine comp forward was the
destruction of the Soviet Union um the
enslavement of its peoples the
starvation of its peoples the seizure of
its territories uh Germany invades the
Soviet Union with the with the largest
Armed Force ever assembled in the
history of the world um that Armed Force
is followed by einot scupin who are
tasked to to kill the Soviet political
classes a point I'm going to return to
in a moment there reasons why we would
expect all of that to accelerate Mass
killing but there's another reason which
often gets overlooked and that has to do
with politics and it's going to take me
a while to explain it but it's
interesting I think it's important it
has to do with the mov rientro PCT okay
now even if you have read a lot of books
about the Holocaust
you Pro you may not know much about The
molto ribbro Pact I'm just going to make
an interesting just a point I think is
interesting the MTO rro PCT is how the
Second World War began right it's the
agreement between the Soviet Union and
Nazi Germany which began the second
world war we might have had a second
world war that began in a different way
in fact it began with a Soviet German
agreement called the maltor P
nevertheless if you read the history of
the Holocaust if even if you're very
very deeply immersed in it you won't
know about the the M fact because it's
usually not even mentioned men or if
it's mentioned it's mentioned as an
afterthought and I think here we we're
right at the Nexus of a basic problem in
the literature which I'm going to try to
solve in the next 45 seconds okay so the
the basic problem is this when Germany
invades the Soviet Union okay I mean
it's easy to cover this with images
right it's a massive war war of
extermination it's very easily almost
exceeds the imagination and when you
read Pros about this moment June 22nd
1941 it's very often like the pros is so
is so Broad and so so grandiose that you
forget what's actually at play what's
actually at play When the Germans invade
the Soviet Union they're not invading
the Soviet Union they're invading
territories that the Soviet Union has
just taken from Poland and they're
invading the Baltic states okay the
first few days and weeks of the invasion
are not in the pre-war Soviet Union
they're in territories which the Soviet
Union has just invaded now we struggle
with this we struggle and struggle and
struggle because geography is not our
strong suit and the Europeans struggle
and struggle and struggle because polish
geography is not their strong suit um
but but this is really important because
what it means is that when the when the
Germans invade the Soviet Union on the
22nd of June 1941 what they are
encountering is territory where the
Soviets have themselves just invaded and
where the Soviets have themselves just
carried out policies of State
destruction which are actually rather
mature rather efficient and rather well
carried out compared to the German
equivalents the it's not that the Soviet
intentions are worse I wouldn't want to
say that but their practices are
actually rather more effective um than
the German ones so when the Germans
arrive they're encountering a sovietized
population they're encountering a
population where the elites have already
been murdered or deported they're
encountering a situation where this is
important expropriation has already
happened right the Soviets didn't
expropriate Jews as such they
expropriated everybody but in towns and
cities in this part of Europe the the
trading class and the professional class
were were very largely Jewish which
meant that de facto the Soviets had
already expropriated the Jews and
there's a political Factor political
factor is huge the Soviets had
eliminated the Estonian lvan and and
Lithuanian States entirely entirely now
this is why The molto rro Pact is so
hard because the lithuanians the Lathan
and the estonians they don't want you to
forget about the Malto verro PCT because
it extinguished their sovereignty they
want you to know that it happened
because they want you know how bad the
Soviet Union was okay fine but there's
another reason why the malov veran tract
matters so much and that is that It
prepares the way for what's going to
happen next to Jews simple overall
General claim when a state is destroyed
this is worse not for the national
majorities the national majorities
control the
historiography um they're the ones who
are going to tell you why it's bad later
on but in fact it's worse for National
minorities the end of a state is worse
for National minorities and if you're
not if you're not with me just think for
a minute about what's ja in Syria the
examples can be multiplied and
multiplied okay so the multi rro p is
actually most significant for Jews and
here's why when the Germans enter into
these territories they find that they
have opportunities that they did not
know that they had what they thought was
going to happen and this was kind of
their Nazi naive T was that the local
inferior subhuman peoples were going to
rise up against their Jewish communist
Masters and Carry Out lots of pgrs now
there were many pges every single one of
them took place after the Germans
arrived and instigated it in one way or
another those pgrs were awful but they
did not lead in a straight line to the
final solution what happens instead is
in a way much worse what happens instead
is that the Germans arrive in a
situation where essentially everyone had
been this is the turkey political part
essentially everyone had been implicated
in the Soviet project there the
difference between the Soviet project
and the Nazi project is that the Nazi
project is racial so it includes some
but excludes most the Soviet project
whatever its flaws which I'm happy to
discuss is inclusive it's about
including everyone when the Soviet Union
expands it brings what it has at home to
you it brings its same system to you it
equalizes which means that as of 1941 to
a degree that the Germans could not have
understood and did not understand local
populations whether they're lithuanians
or Jews or Russians it doesn't matter
have been implicated in the Soviet
system now the Germans come punching
into this territory with their judeo
bulvik idea right they come in here
saying the Jews are communists and the
Communists are Jews and that creates the
opportunity for a politics which the
Germans themselves don't understand and
which you can't find in German sources
which is one of the major problems you
can find it in local sources and in
Jewish sources because the Jews watch
this and they're astonished and they
write it down what happens is that
non-jews who are of course the majority
of the Soviet collaborators say oh yes
of course the Jews are communists and
the Communists are Jews because that is
their way out of their Soviet past right
that is the thing which makes them safe
under the German occupation and that is
the dynamic which allows Jews whether
regardless of how much they collaborated
to be punished and killed okay and then
once Jews are killed for being
communists whether they were or not very
often by people who were Communists
incidentally when that happens it then
has to be true you see so the once you
kill Jews for being communists then for
generations to come and I'm talking
right up to the present people then have
to believe that the Jews were commun
Communists because the idea that you
killed them for nothing which is what
happened or the idea that you killed
them for your own collaboration is
unbearable right and from that Source we
get the ethnic stereotypes that Prevail
today okay that was a long explanation
there's another there's another politics
here which is really important imagine
that um an entire state which you are
from is wiped out right imagine that
Canada is wiped out by America France is
wiped out by just let your imaginations
roam free okay it's not something that
we generally have to deal with in the
west although it does happen in other
places what happens then is that a
political resource is created right if
Lithuania for example is destroyed then
there are going to be a certain number
of lithuanians who are going to be ready
to collaborate with whatever is coming
next right and the story that the
Germans said tell them is um these more
educated these more political
collaborators is the project we want you
to collaborate with is the destruction
of the Jews and then all conversations
about other politics follow that now I'm
not trying to remove responsibility from
these people and I'm not trying to say
that the Soviets were worse and it was
all their fault what I'm trying to do is
say the prior destruction of states is
what makes that politics possible if
Lithuania Latvia and Estonia are not
destroyed then you can't have
lithuanians who are willing to
collaborate generally we call these
people nationalists and many of them
were but I would just point out that
many of us would have a certain reaction
if our state were completely destroyed
by one of its neighbors you don't have
to be a nationalist to think that that's
a bad thing and to believe that
something ought to be done to restore it
so what happens then is that with the
invasion of the Soviet
Union in the summer of 1941 the final
solution then becomes a holocaust and I
almost want to say finally becomes a
holocaust because it's eight years after
Hitler has come to power and a very
particular thing has to happen and what
happens to make it very brief is that
the einot scoop and come through they
realize that local people can be
recruited to collaborate
this is not part of the plan there's no
plan very important there's no plan
there's never a plan there's no plan um
they really that Hitler personally for
for forbids arming local people but they
do it anyway within days local people
can be recruited they can be recruited
for these various political economic and
sometimes anti-semitic or nationalist
reasons um that one can form militias
auxiliary police and that one can kill
the Jews an opportunity emerges which
hadn't been there before and what the
Germans realize is that this notion that
the Jews can be eradicated has now taken
on a form a form which they had not
planned for which they had not
anticipated I I think honestly they did
not expect which is that the Jews can be
killed where they lived the Germans
learned this in practice they learned it
about locals I've been emphasizing this
but they also learned it about
themselves they learned it about
themselves so when the einot scopin come
in there's no reason to doubt that
they're going to follow orders their
orders are and this is this is important
to destroy the Soviet political class
just like their orders in 1939 in Poland
were to destroy the Polish political
class the Soviet political class though
is defined as being heavily Jewish so
when they come in they're killing lots
of people but many of them are Jews of
military age this slips very quickly
into being all Jews right and it slips
partly because of the locals but not
entirely it also has to do with the fact
that the Germans turn out to be able to
recruit themselves so the einot school
when we're not thinking about the camps
we're thinking about the einot scin the
einot scin did not kill most of the Jews
on the Eastern Front the German order
police the ordin the uniform police the
people who help you across the street
those people killed more Jews than the
einot cin they were present at every
major Mass killing um and and uh and in
the end of the day they're probably more
significant the verm also kills a very
large number of Jews the Germans did not
know the Nazi leadership did not know
that their own people in conditions of
statelessness in these very special
conditions of Anarchy could be brought
in to this project and that is how the
Holocaust proves to be possible it
proves to be possible in this condition
of double State destruction during the
invasion of the Soviet Union because
enough locals and enough Germans will
take part now this is important because
it's in my view it's the fact of killing
which makes the final solution seem
plausible if we remember there weren't
the gassing facilities don't exist yet
okay they don't exist yet um and they
are a consequence of all this not a
cause if we remember there's no plan
there is not a plan there's no plan
about how this is to be done this is
learned in practice and so this the it's
the weight of the brute fact that a
million Jews are murdered by December
1941 which makes a final solution seem
plausible now once you realize that as
Hitler seems very clearly to have done
right around December 1941 once you
realize that a final solution is
possible in this way that you had not
anticipated well then you press forward
you press forward into the pre-war
Soviet Union where very high percentages
of Jews are killed well over 90% And you
move backwards into Poland and in Poland
also very high numbers well over 90% of
Jews are killed the Jews are remember
already gathered in ghettos and they can
be sent from the from the ghettos to
gasing facilities now the gasing
facilities just to make a point very
briefly the gasing facilities are not
the result of some far- ranging plan
they are not the emanation of Hightech
technology or Enlightenment or anything
like that they are the result of a
series of improvisations designed to
reduce the number of Germans who have to
kill face to face the Germans start
gassing with vans in the East um they do
it so they don't have to look at
children while they're killing them the
technology involved is just shunting the
exhaust pipe back into the hold of the
van that's not high technology right
it's very easy um the next Innovation or
technology if you like technique is that
you park the Vans that's it that's Helm
no that's the killing facil heln you
park the Vans take the wheels off put
them on blocks that's Helm no the next
Innovation high technology not high at
all is that you take the internal
combustion engine out of the vehicle
that's it and then you pipe the exhaust
into a sealed chamber that's trinka
belet soie board the next Innovation
after that is outfits where once you've
realized you can use a sealed chamber
use hydren hydrogen cyanide instead of
exhaust this is not high technology
right this is improvisation basically
based on what's to hand so it's the
killing as I see it the crucial thing is
the learning that this can be done the
technique is not so crucial and when we
get it backwards what I'm trying to say
is we have this image of AIT to some
kind of end of history or modernity or
some kind of black hole or some kind of
poetic something or other um we're
priting ourselves from seeing this
historically because alitz is actually a
kind of side effect of the Holocaust not
it's not the Holocaust it's it's one
technique of carrying out the Holocaust
very late okay
now the largest Massacre that happens or
the first large scale Massacre which
takes place um is at a town that you
have not heard of a city you've not
heard of called kamanat podilsky kamanat
pilki is in Southwestern Ukraine um in
kames pilki at the end of August 1941
around 23,600 Jews are shot nothing like
that had ever happened before in the
history of the world unfortunately
things like that would then continue to
happen a few weeks later in babiar
outside Kiev um
33761 Jews would be shot but it's Kaman
pilki which proved it was possible and I
want to dwell on this place um because
it reveals something important about
this argument from the state thus far
what I've tried to claim is that it's
the acceleration of the process of State
destruction the mutation of the German
State destruction of Austria
Czechoslovakia increasingly violently
Poland and the Soviet Union which
enables the Holocaust to happen let's
now reverse the field and ask um how
does the state protect Jews or why is
the state relevant to Jews Kaman pilki
shows us something very
important when Czechoslovakia was
destroyed Here Comes obscure history
sorry when Czechoslovakia was destroyed
in 1938 and 1939 it was divided up into
various bits one of the bits was subar
subcarpathian ruthenia right
subcarpathian ruthenia is taken by
Hungary Hungary does not recognize the
Jews in subcarpathian ruthenia as its
citizens when the ger when Germany
invades the Soviet Union in 1941 what
does Hungary do it expels those Jews
from subcarpathian ruthenia Eastward
over the Soviet border right into the
path of the Germans and that is what
prompts the massacre at Kaman pki now
the reason why I stress that is it all
begins with the destruction of
Czechoslovakia um and it's possible
because Hungary doesn't recognize the
citizenship of its own Jews and this is
actually key because whether we whether
we want to see this or not and often we
don't the passport actually stops the
bullet
the Germans aspirations are total and
their achievements are horrifying but
what they will not do is kill Jews who
are recognized as Citizens by States so
other states take part in the Holocaust
in so far as they ex dep patriate their
own citizens and in so far as they
expatriate their they take citizenship
away and send them away that happens
sometimes but it doesn't happen always
or to put this in a very general way if
you are a Jew on territory which was
rendered stateless your chance of
surviving was less than one in 20 if you
were a Jew on a territory where there
was a state your chance of surviving was
one in two which is horrible it's worse
than anyone else in the second world war
but it's very different a whole order of
magnitude different from one in 20
there's there are mechanisms for this
which which I don't have time to
describe but the point is that once you
move out of the zone of statelessness
into the rest of Europe it becomes
harder I'll just give you a couple of
more very brief observ ations about this
consider the following things in Denmark
99% of the Jews survive there is a very
pleasant story which is fundamentally
false about how this happens the main
reason this happens is that the Danish
occupation was a traditional military
occupation in which danus institutions
were essentially untouched if you want
we can go into how it actually happens
in Q&A in Estonia um 99% of the Jews are
killed is Estonia more anti-semitic than
Denmark no if anything clearly less so
the difference is um did did did Estonia
take refugees in 1930s yes did Denmark
no and so on um but in Denmark all the
Jews die why because of the double
occupation because of the double State
destruction in France 75% of the Jews
survive in the Netherlands 75% die is
that because the French are less
anti-semitic than the Dutch no one
thought so at the time including the
Jews no one thinks so now right um
including historians I mean these are
not just stereotypes the reason why is
that the Netherlands were the only
country in western Europe where the SS
were the state destroyers were literally
the guy who had destroyed Austria say
inat um the state destroyers are in
charge of the occupation and that makes
all the difference or consider the
Holocaust in France here's something
astounding which I think every book on
the Holocaust in France should begin
with more polish Jews die in the
Holocaust in France than French Jews
more polish Jews die in the Holocaust in
France than French Jews and of course
there are many many many many more
French Jews than polish Jews the reason
why in absolute numbers more polish Jews
die is that they have no State
protection right which means that the
French state is in different to their
fate in fact they're the kind of people
that the French State wants to get rid
of so if you run if you look at it this
way each story is different right you
have to tell the story of Hungary and
Romania and Italy in detail but the
general rule is very clear the more
sovereignty there is the better off the
Jews are going to be and roughly
speaking this is for three reasons which
I've already suggested the first is
citizenship if you you are a citizen and
your state does not take your
citizenship away you're going to
survive the Germans are not going to
take you as a Romanian Jew into aitz in
1943 because Romania doesn't want you to
go so they won't take you um the second
is foreign policy if you're a sovereign
state you can decide that the Americans
and the British care a lot about your
Jews which was not really as true as
anti-semitic governments thought it was
but you can decide the Americans and the
British care a lot about your Jews and
you can switch sides and to signal that
you're switching sides you can change
your Jewish policy which is what Romania
did and what Hungary tried to do the
third thing which matters is bureaucracy
now in the literature in the Holocaust
and admittedly in everyday experience
bureaucracy has a bad name but
bureaucracy is not what killed the Jews
in Germany the German bureaucrats never
even decided in to the end what German
what what a Jew was the German
bureaucracy does not kill any Jews
inside Germany the only way to kill Jews
is to send them to bureaucracy free
zones which you yourself have created
where do the German Jews die they die in
Ria they die in Minsk they die in wuj
they die in cities which before the war
were thriving Jewish metropolises but
which German occupation transformed into
the black holes that are described in
German Jewish Memoirs we look at these
cities through the lenses of the German
Jews who go there and we see them as as
places of death but they were made into
places of death by the by the
destruction of the states around them
okay this in turn instructs us as to
what rescue means so I'm going to now
try to tell you very practical and I
hope plausible account of how rescuing
Jews was possible um if you've come this
far then you'll already know who the
main Rescuers are going to be the main
Rescuers of Jews are
diplomats why because diplomats um are
the people who are capable of giving you
a piece of paper which gives you state
recognition right so therefore the
Chinese Consul in Vienna could rescue a
couple thousand Jews therefore um Ral
valenberg who was was the only American
anti- Holocaust policy because we paid
for fallenberg um he was an amateur
Swedish Diplomat who came to Budapest um
he saved thousands of Jews by giving
them Transit papers or sugihara the
Japanese Consul in CIS in Lithuania also
saved thousands of Jews by giving them
Transit papers diplomats were the people
who could save they were the only people
in fact who could save very large
numbers of Jews because they had the
power to extend State recognition when
you move down from the diplomats it
becomes a little bit cloudier churches
sometimes yes but usually no and the
churches who did interestingly were the
churches who were marginal Before the
War people who were oppressed before the
war were more likely to to rescue
paramilitaries and uh partisan armies
sometimes yes sometimes no right there's
nobody on the planet who likes both the
Polish home Army and the Soviet
partisans but in one fundamental way
they were basically similar which was
sometimes they killed Jews and sometimes
they rescued them because to make it
short they were partially State
institutions and partially not when you
work your way all the way down to
individuals to the people who in the
book I call the righteous few you find
yourself in a very unusual Zone because
it turns out and this is not surprising
though it's sobering it turns out that
people who can rescue without
institutional support surrounded by
conditions of Anarchy when the incentive
structures are all pointy towards giving
Jews away or killing them there are not
very many people like that and when you
reach those people you're actually
reaching the end of the history in a way
you're reaching the end of the story
because you're reaching into a place
that you cannot explain structurally
because these people are behaving in a
way which you cannot account for by
traditional motivation right there's a
motivation is something that connects
you to the outside world this is not
generally something these people have
they generally have something which the
people who who who they rescued describe
as Humanity that's the word which
appears a lot menite um something which
actually seems to go beyond the context
these tend to be people who take moral
Norms a little bit too literally and
therefore their hold on moral Norms is
less affected when the whole world
around them changes there are not that
many people like that which brings me to
the conclusion if if this account of the
Holocaust is anything like correct then
there then then then we need to build
much beyond the idea of following The
Rescuers and seeing them as an example
because in the conditions in which the
Holocaust took place not many of us
would be able to do that I am not Prim
aasia convinced that we are morally uh
superior to the Europeans of the 1930s I
see very little idence of that in fact
when I look at the Europeans in 1930s I
see the ability to defer gratification
and do all kinds of things which we seem
to have lost so there there there's I
think there's no particular case to make
that we have learned in fact I'm
extremely skeptical of that I tend to
think that we've learned the thing which
is most convenient to us which has to do
with identity and the problem with
identity is the moment that times get
tough your identity changes and you
forget your previous identity you put
someone else in a barn and burn them and
you blame them for your previous
identity and it's all over that's what
happens not just to polls in 1941 but to
everybody so I I worry about identity as
the lesson that we should learn I worry
even about ethics as the only lesson
that we should learn it seems like there
are structural lessons and there are two
of them and they're fairly clear one of
them is that this eological Panic is
politics we've been bracketed from that
by the Green Revolution right we are the
only people ever in the history of the
world not just us personally but the the
people in the west of the last three
generations are the only people in the
history of the world for whom food has
not been a political
issue what if that changes or what if
the perception of that changes and I
don't mean just in America but what if
in a place like China right what if in a
place like China which is already
leasing 10% of the arable soil in
Ukraine and which is already in effect
colonizing a great deal of East Africa
what about in a place like China is an
idea of laen Realm today so implausible
for a place like China an industrial
power which is not able to secure its
own food supplies and so on right what
about in a place like China um
ecological Panic can strike at many
different levels there's the local level
like Rwanda
Sudan Syria right Syria today now
there's a genocide going on in Syria now
um and then there's the regional level
and then there's the global level where
I think China and Africa is perhaps a
place to watch the second lesson has to
do with the state both from the right
and from the left um we have drawn
conclusions about from the Holocaust
which have to do with the need to weaken
or fragment or limit the state I think
this is exactly backwards um the lesson
of the Holocaust is that states protect
even imperfect States even flawed states
protect citizens and so as important as
debates about what kind of state it
should be and what the ideology should
be um the state itself turns out to be a
good and so I would draw at least the
very limited conclusion that Wars like
the American war in Iraq in 2003 or the
Soviet War in Ukraine Russian war in
Ukraine in 2014 which used the Holocaust
as moral for destroying States I'd make
the minimal claim that that's a mistake
right and I would make the maximal claim
that bolstering states as a positive
good or bolstering institutions which
bolster States is probably a rather good
thing now these are the lessons that I
would draw here not because I think
individual behavior is unimportant right
that The Rescuers have to be remembered
and I spent an awful lot of time in this
book tracking down Yiddish sources
polish sources Russian sources Ukrainian
sources about rescue a good deal of this
book is devoted to rescue it's not that
I think that they're unimportant it's
that I think that they're all but
unattainable and that we have to be
realistic about the historical setting
and being realistic about the historical
setting means acting at moments when you
can act rather than waiting for that
sensation of panic to come and the
belief that you can't actually do things
that's what that's what Hitler
cultivated that sense that you can do
nothing except strike out right we are
never very far away from that but I
think if we take the history of the
Holocaust seriously we can learn some of
the mechanisms to keep our distance from
that so that's what I would take the
public policy lessons of all this to be
thank you very
[Applause]
much
yeah see I mean if if you take the
lecture seriously you actually have to
go out and change the world right away
right that is that is the spirit of yell
undergraduates that is what they are
doing okay so um uh I'll start back
there so I have a question about the
role of the
N both in terms of and sorry the role of
what I missed
it National Socialist National Socialist
yeah United Workers Party In terms and
terms
absorbing and what
of yeah
so in the way that I narrate this
history it's very much an international
history where I'm trying to take the
standard narration um where we spend an
awful lot of time on Germany 1930s and
then kind of spill over to the rest of
the world without having previously
examined it I'm trying to turn that
inside out and see what happens so I'm
I'm I'm putting in the book I put
Austria and Czechoslovakia and Poland
and the Baltic states and the Soviet
Union in play before they get destroyed
which which is really important because
then you have a sense not only of who
the Jews are where they lived under what
conditions you also have a chance of
understanding how important it is when
those conditions go away which means
that the way that I'm reading national
socialism is of course a little bit
different because I I'm reading national
socialism also internationally so I'm
reading national socialism as a a I'm
taking it seriously as a racial movement
and as a racial movement it cannot
entirely be about taking power in
Germany or transforming the German state
it must be about International
transformation I'm taking that for
granted and I think that's a I think
that's a fruitful assumption um in in
terms of in terms of ger inside Germany
outside Germany the the National
Socialist Party and it's a good question
because I just emphasized esss the
National Socialist Party is not the kind
of party which is just there to win
power they win power but it can it can
only be as an instrument to go further
right so given what they believe the
world is like winning elections cannot
be the end of the story and Western
Observers who looked at Hitler and said
now that he's one power he's all he's
going to calm down they they they they
had to be wrong um in terms of in terms
of the rest of Europe the basic story in
Eastern Europe which is the crucial part
is that the the there are three kinds of
occupations roughly speaking there's the
civilian occupations which are the
civilian authorities which are generally
run by old guards Old Guard Nazis um and
then there's military occupation which
is out in front geographically of the
civilian occupation zones but then on
top of that is the SS and it's the SS
which turns out to be most important and
there's a pol there's a political story
here which I tell in this book and in
the other one about how it's easier for
the SS to achieve its Nazi goals than it
is for the party to achieve its Nazi
goals because what the party is supposed
to be doing is things like keeping order
and extracting food both of which turn
out to be rather hard whereas what the
SS is supposed to be doing is racial
transformation some kinds of that turn
out to be hard all the kinds involving
deportation the Germans actually make a
massive deportation they're Terri
terrible L compared to the Soviets um
but the parts that involve killing
people where they live the SS gets
rather good at that and then that's what
that's the mission they take credit for
so himler says you know the East belongs
to the SS and this is what he means
they're actually able to carry out their
mission faster than and it seems like
you know Silly familiar bureaucratic
infighting and it was but just with
terrific with terrifying
consequences um another another thing is
like the the it's you can compare Poland
with the east a little bit here because
the further east you go the more the
more Authority the SS has or and and so
so like the end of the the mass murder
of the Jews in the waral ghetto is the
moment where the civilian Authority
which is also Nazi gives way to SS
Authority right okay um yeah so um it's
very compelling that state distance very
dangerous to the National minorities but
isn't it isn't the overing state
dangerous andal to thetion majorities as
the Soviet Union perhaps was and maybe
on a much smaller scale in Syria now so
it's a difficult Choice who do we say
that the question yeah yeah yeah yeah no
I'm obviously like Mak making this you
know almost unbelievably conservative
claim that like states are a good thing
right like I'm s of thrown back into the
17th century with this argument um is is
obviously not a Utopia right I'm not
claiming that it exhausts everything
that has to be said on the subject I am
saying though that if what is one if
what if what is if what is one if what
one is concerned about is the the
physical extermination of minorities
than the state itself um especially in
so far as the state recognizes those
people as Citizens is is a barrier and
that surprisingly even flawed States
like even anti-semitic states are are
this is a you know this is a finding
even anti-semitic states are better than
no State at all right so Germany which
you can't really deny is an anti-semitic
state only manages to kill about half of
its Jews probably a little bit less but
in places where Germany goes and
displaces state power it manages to kill
almost all of of the Jews um or Romania
which is indisputably an anti-semitic
regime um they kill less than half of
their Jews and and they switch their
policy they they shift from killing them
to not to not killing them um and then
you know there are other things that are
interesting about this like for
example where Jews die in Europe beyond
the stateless zones very often
it's if you look closely you see that
it's something like a stateless zone so
in Bulgaria for example the bulgarians
have a story about how they save their
Jews which is kind of true but it's that
the Jews who they sent to die were the
Jews who were on the territory that they
gained right so there was a regime
change which meant that there was a
moment when those Jews didn't have
citizenship and then they were sent to
aitz and died the Jews from th Macedonia
um even Romania the Jews who are on
Romanian territory at the beginning of
the war almost all them survived I mean
a couple tens of thousands which is not
trivial die but almost all surviv the
Jews who die are the ones who are in
territory which the Soviet Union takes
so regime change and Romania takes back
and interestingly when the Romanians go
back into the Soviet Union they tell the
exact same judeo bulvik story that the
Germans do and they know it's not true
the Germans know the Germans don't know
it's not true I mean the Germans are
naive on this stuff the Romanians know
it's not true and they say it anyway
they tell they they come the Romanians
come back and they tell Romanians who
are trying to take revenge on Romanian
Communists we are only taking revenge on
Jews because Jews are communists and
Communists are Jews um but I I take your
point of course and and I mean the way I
would handle it in a broad way would be
to say that the states which have proven
to be capable of large scale Mass
killing very large scale like on the
scale of millions are are party States
so unconventional states where the
Locust of political loyalty is actually
beyond the state Administration and the
state Administration is seen as inferior
to the party so that would be People's
Republic of China Cambodia and the
Soviet Union um and then the you know
the other major findings so what I'm
saying about statelessness actually this
is is is consistent with um a huge set
of findings from the the genocide
studies field and the ethnic conflict
field which has emerged since basically
the the war in Yugoslavia so in the last
quarter Century there have now been
thousands of studies and their basic
finding is that its conditions of Civil
War regime change and change of
boundaries which favor ethnic cleansing
so what's special about Germany is that
Germany's a party State okay but it's a
party state which doesn't kill citizens
its own citizens so much it's a party
state which creates the conditions of
political chaos Beyond its own borders
so what's special about Nazi Germany is
it brings together like these two
historical findings um that party states
can kill lots of people and that state
destruction kills lots of people they're
a party state which generates State
destruction ction beyond their own
borders now it's not to say that there
aren't bad States like like like Syria
it's not to say that there aren't
abusive States but it's even even a
place like Syria where you know God God
knows it's hard to imagine how things
could be worse but even a place like
Syria so long as you're talking about an
authoritarian regime um who's that it's
oppressing its own people it cannot
unleash a kind of international
catastrophe of this sort the only way to
do that is to go beyond your own borders
um and authoritarian regimes actually
you know they don't NE neily do
that okay so Jen you had a question yeah
so in the last chapter of the book you
make this really striking statement that
globalization brings a specific
intellectual danger and you note that
Hitler was a child of the first wave of
globalization in the late 19th century
were all products of the second wave or
a second wave of globalization in the
late 20th century and I was just
wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit more on the argument that
you're making about the intellectual and
indeed political dangers of
globalization right so yeah so the first
point you've already made which is that
globalization is not new it's not new we
can study it because it already happened
once um Hitler's generation was a
globalized generation the thing which
the Germans called vandel um in the
1870s ' 80s 90s up to the first world
war basically with the digging of canals
right the Panama Canal the Suez Canal
the expansion of World Trade dramatic at
a dramatic rate um um the Victorian the
late Victorian Prosperity you know which
one SE so clearly in in in English
literature from the period these things
were globalization this was these were
were Global and like any globalization
here's my answer to your question it
globalization tends to bring about
mental shortcuts because we can't really
handle that level of analysis right we
can handle a few people a group a nation
we can do but that's like a big step of
imagination which already requires a lot
of abstraction but the whole planet
right the whole planet begs for
shortcuts and the the idea that the Jews
are in charge is one shortcut right it's
one it's one way of organizing the way
it's one way of organizing the planet
and it's one which people found many
people found unfortunately quite
convincing now when I say there's a
specific danger I mean that in in a
world which isn't globalized where
you're not thinking where Hitler's not
thinking about housewives in
America um then because Hitler was he
was a global thinker I mean that's
that's a kind of like I sound like you
know I don't know Hillary Clinton when I
say Global thinker cu Global is a word
now that has entirely positive
connotations right or almost am I right
about this when you say Global you mean
something good like the Jackson
Institute for Global Effect you mean
something good when you say Global right
you mean positive Cosmopolitan Forward
Thinking Jim levenson's already gone I'm
in good shape um the uh you mean
something forward thinking positive you
know over the horizon um but but but but
Global is that is all is is dangerous
too I mean Hitler was a global thinker
okay so I didn't talk about this very
much I only referred to America but
Hitler thought about the whole world I
mean he thought that he thought that um
the American frontier experience was a
positive model for Germany and he wasn't
alone I mean two whole generations of
German colonialists thought that the
Germans who colonized Africa they
referred to America all the time when
they were when they were Exterminating
African peoples they said this is
necessary look at America right they
referred to their own colonies as our
Wyoming right the these they referred
yeah I mean not only I don't mean to
pick on Wyoming that wasn't the only
they also mentioned Montana and some
other states but they saw the American
model as part of as part as part of one
history right as part of one history so
a little Hitler would play um Cowboys
and Indians and he would play um at
African wars right and it in a way it
was the same thing right it was the same
thing a little Hitler would read Carl
Mai um about I don't mean what he did
like millions of other German children
would read Carl Mai about the American
West take that in and also read the
newspapers about African wars and it was
all one story for him so that that
globalization was about was about
colonialism and that's the lesson that
people learned right and when Hitler was
thinking about laan he was thinking
globally he was thinking the British
control um he thought like this the
British like free trade because they're
the only ones who can control the sea
lanes because they have a big Navy which
is all totally true he says the British
are the ones who support free trade
because they're the only ones who would
be able to fight their way out of it if
there's some kind of problem also
totally true right but that is a that is
global thinking and his reaction to that
is laan swelm we have to become a third
great power after the British after the
rising Americans we have to become a
third great power he's thinking at the
level of the planet which is what Carl
Schmidt you know your friend and mine
you know rising star of of this just
befuddles me but rising star of the
international left right now Carl
Schmidt this is what Carl Schmidt said
that we all think in planetary terms now
right we all think in planetary terms so
what I mean is that Glo globalization um
raises the level of complex to such an
extent that people look for shortcuts um
and and they look for examples which
sometimes they mutate a little bit when
they apply them to their own
territory yes please whenit was writing
about this idea the national Order of
Things natural be racial Warfare over
resources did he talk about how he enion
the races or
RAC yeah interestingly he was much
vaguer on that question than one might
think it's there there is an Aryan race
and the Aryan race says Hitler is
responsible for most of the good
inventions um whether it's art whether
it's science uh he says that they're
responsible for most of the progress but
it's a little bit unclear who they are
you know where they came from who they
are now it's he doesn't mean the Germans
he means the Germans plus like maybe the
Dutch and the Scandinavians it's not
just the Germans when he talks about the
Germans he talks about the German folk
the German people what's interesting is
that he thinks the German people the
folk their nationalism like this is this
kind of it's this thing to be exploited
they're nationalist so so you use that
to send them into war war against Poland
and you tell them it's all about Danzig
or it's all about the borders but it's
not at all about those things it's about
destroying the Polish state and
beginning a racial War but anyway to
answer your question he's much less
clear about that but I mean there's a
way in which his Clarity actually makes
a kind of sense because his view of
races was entirely pragmatic and so kind
of post-factum because he thought race
is always struggle and the Victorious
races are victorious races so it's kind
of circular right which led to the
famous you know notorious moment at the
end of the war when he says well the
Germans the Germans have lost so it
turns out they're not actually such a
superior race the history now belongs to
he says the younger peoples of the East
so you know so his view is like okay I
made a mistake um but I was
fundamentally right it's all about
racial struggle I just was wrong about
the Germans and that's a way that he's
not accidentally not a nationalist right
because I think no nationalist could
could say um oh I just made a mistake
and destroyed my own people right but
but that's all that's to the good in the
end because this is all a big laboratory
experiment about which races are
stronger okay I'm going to take a couple
more and then so because yeah so so okay
I'll take three more all right um so so
maybe J you first yeah I have a question
about uh logical consistency in this
ideology I'm just wondering how you sare
seems to be a conflict on one the mod
that you you began your talk with that
that race shouldn't sacrifice its goals
on the altar of the state the idea that
the revolution should devour itself the
state should devour itself in the name
of international transformation how do
you square that with the idea of uh the
SS or Nazi refence
for
the boundaries the state when it came to
protecting thew it seems
like
Jude should out in that kind of scenario
and I'm wondering how Okay so first of
all like let's let's recognize even
without my big claims at the beginning
of the talk let's recognize how
interesting it is that the passport did
stop the bullet I that that's that's
something that I think we you could
start a whole history of the Holocaust
like from that claim and you would you
would you would end up with a very
different kind of trajectory than the
ones that we usually have and it's true
I mean it's the Germans had the hardest
time deatria in their own Jews it took
them they you know they made them second
class citizens they took away some of
their property rights they eventually
got many of them out but within their
own State they couldn't just take all
the as it were all the passports away
they couldn't even do that right which
raises the question of just like how
powerful the state was or how complete
Nazi control was they couldn't find a
way to do that within the state the only
way to do it was to get those people
physically into a into a bureaucracy
free zone somewhere somewhere in the in
the East and and so what I'm saying is
that the Germans fundamental the Nazis
fundamentally believe that the truth
about the world was the racial struggle
but in the racial struggle people did
have instruments right it's not that
they didn't believe in um it's not that
Hitler literally didn't believe in
science right I mean he believed in
artillery um he even believed in the
agricultural technology he just didn't
believe that it could change the
fundamental condition of the world which
was racial struggle and so it's not that
the Germans or the Nazis denied that
states existed it's that they thought
states are fundamentally a means rather
than an end and in the end will all be
overcome but in the meantime you can't
pretend that states don't exist anymore
than you can pretend that the enemy's
artillery doesn't exist it's out there
if you if you ran the Nazis are
perfectly aware that if they killed
American Jewish citizens who happen to
be tourists that very bad things would
happen as a result of that so it's
you're right that that I don't think
it's actually a contradiction I mean
they were they they would have wanted a
world in which all states collapsed into
some kind of racial competition I think
they would have wanted that world or all
states were subordinate to races
something like that but in the meantime
Hitler was perfectly aware of the
constraints he faced and and that's true
all the way through the story I mean
your question highlights something which
is true all the way through the story
which is that when Hitler needs to win
elections he's perfectly aware of what
he's facing in terms of public opinion
right that's how he comes to power when
Hitler has to transform the German State
he's perfectly aware of how slow he has
to go he doesn't just he doesn't you
know jump for joy in March of 1933 and
say I'm going to wave my hand to make it
all go away he slowly slowly slowly
transforms this bit that bit and the
other bit and I think it's the same with
with foreign states he knows that
they're real even though that you know
in his worldview eventually they should
all collapse in the meantime they're
real and you have to deal with them uh
so yeah I mean you know this this is
like I I think this is just really I
think it's really interesting um in a
way like that's the Paradox in both
domestic and foreign policy right how do
you come to power when you're a racial
Anarchist he solves that how do you kill
lots of Jews when you're once you start
the war he also solves that I mean not
completely but he he finds a way to
solve it which is you create zones where
there is no sovereignty um I mean or to
put it a different way like if if if it
weren't if if statehood weren't a
problem then he wouldn't have to destroy
States but what they I mean I'm
answering this abstractly but what they
learned they learned in practice they
actually learn that you can get rid of
Jews as States collapse they learn that
in practice but that doesn't mean that
states have collapsed everywhere
or okay I said two more right so um how
about Stephen and that sorry how about
Steph and then
Carolina thank
you a wonderful presentation uh can you
draw any parallels between Hitler's uh
uh political philosophy that you that
you described and president
uh political leaders such as Vladimir
Putin well I I would hesitate to do that
but fortunately President
Putin does it himself right so he has
embarked on a Nostalgia campaign about
the 1930s which leads right up to and
includes the idea that the Malto rro PCT
was a pretty good thing so rather than
my doing it I just prefer to kind of sit
and listen because what he is saying and
I think this is a very important claim
for Europeans is that you know things
like European union or any kind of you
know transnational law those things
don't really matter the real world the
good world the world that you know real
men want is the world of the 1930s right
when nations were Nations and men were
men you know that's that's what he wants
and so he's right up to the point where
he says Stalin and Hitler were rational
you know rational actors who were just
doing what power does so the par I don't
like the idea of parallels you know but
I don't mind pointing out that Putin has
rehabilitated the malov rientro PCT
twice once in front of his own local
historians and the second time in front
of Chancellor
Miracle uh so I'll just leave it at that
and then kolina and then I want to make
sure everyone has can you know get home
before midnight okay um so mine's a
little bit more specific but I was
wondering how you would or how you do
fit the Polish underground State into
this narrative so a state that's far
away abroad but an apparatus that still
works on the ground
yeah that's a great question and in the
book I spent a lot of time on these
quazi State apparat because it no
precisely because it's so important
because you're on this Continuum right
so you say the Polish state I say the
Polish State's destroyed but it's not
quite destroyed you know I mean there
there are places in the countryside
where it's utterly transformed and then
there are like neighborhoods or maybe
even individual Apartments where in some
sense it functions and the case I try to
make is that where polish Jews are saved
or helped it is surprisingly often the
result of the reach of that very weak
and distant Polish state and the two
examples are jagot um which is so there
aren't actually that many policies by
European states to save Jews Like
America had one um uh the Poland had one
and it was called zoto was a cold name
was a code name for a government
organization which unified and funded um
people who already in Warsaw had been
trying to help Jews in hiding um and it
was the money incidentally came from The
Joint so the way that joto worked was
that the the Polish state was in action
because it was polish paratroopers
dropped from dropped by British PLS over
polish territory occupied polish
territory with in their money belts cash
which came from American Jews uh from
The Joint um and then that was then
delivered to jagota which was a Polish
government institution in Warsaw also in
other cities and used to try to help the
several thousand polish Jews were in
hiding so probably you know a few
thousand Jews were saved as a result of
that and that was actually a government
policy the second thing which is worth
mentioning is um the Allied warnings of
um December 1942 January 1943 to
Germany's allies um not to continue the
persecution of Jews there were other
warnings but that was included um those
were in some measure a result of
information that came through Polish
state champ
so this is what Yan karski who's
remembered as an individual but Yan
karski was working for the Polish state
he was a courier um working for the
Polish state he was on an official
mission he wasn't a private individual
and his information brought from Warsaw
had although ksky himself didn't think
so and lived in guilt his entire life
had an effect on British public opinion
on British the British Parliament and on
the level of knowledge of world leaders
it led to um uh uh BBC reports it led to
stories in the times of London and it
was one of the things which led to um
official polish government in Exile
statements about the events we now
called the Holocaust which in turn
contributed to the Allied warnings and
those Allied warnings didn't affect
Germany at all for the reasons that we
discussed that the Nazis were not
actually didn't care about the state or
the nation um but they did affect other
states right so for example Sweden was
probably made more likely to accept the
Danish Jews by these statements right um
governments were probably more inclined
to switch sides as a result of this so
so in that way although it's very
indirect the existence of a Polish state
actually helps so it's like everywhere
you find a Polish state it it ends up
making it a a positive difference
although the total picture in Poland and
German occupation is one of Anarchy and
fragmentation um and that's a story that
I tell you know at lengthen the book
okay I promised I would let the rest of
you go um if you if if you want a book
there are books I can't give them to you
but I can sell them to you for you know
Sarah can sell them to you for if you
have a $20 bill you can leave with a
book um thank you very much for coming
thank you for the
[Applause]
[Music]
discussion